not long ago on the Jimmy Fallon show
was Sophia the humanoid robot who
jokingly said she would destroy the
human race the talk show stirred up some
serious fear in my mind about robots and
their uses and capabilities so today
join me as I dive deeper into this topic
and discuss everything about robots in
today's video I've divided the robots
into three categories robotic deafness
utility and overall Innovation robotic
deafness and athleticism Boston Dynamics
kick-starts this list with its Atlas
robot a six-foot humanoid the company is
currently owned by Hyundai and is risen
to be the leader in robotics deafness
and athleticism since 1992. Atlas is not
only the most athletic humanoid robot
out there but it is also equipped with
stereo cameras and a Laser Rangefinder
for vision designed for search and
rescue its abilities include navigating
rough terrains and manipulating its
habitat Outdoors the robot is so
athletic and technologically advanced in
its movements that it can do backflips
released back in 2013 Atlas was an
absolute breakthrough in humanoid
robotics as it could use easily walk on
snow-covered terrain and uneven surfaces
it could also get up when knocked over
its movements are so lifelike that many
people have speculated that this would
be the Prototype that would eventually
replace human soldiers on the
battlefield but will Atlas replace human
soldiers I have a full video dedicated
to the topic on this channel so you can
check that out as well after this from a
humanoid robot now let's move to a
canine inspired robot again when it
comes to robotic deafness another Boston
Dynamics robot Takes the Cake The Spot
mini is the quietest robot in the world
capable of amazing athletic Feats
weighing in at just 25 kilograms or 55
pounds this all-electric robot can run
jump climb maintain its balance and even
open doors in February 2018 a video of
spot mini opening the door with its claw
did make number one on YouTube's
trending list but most of the footage of
the spot mini that's available online is
the robot performing in its autonomous
mode but what many people don't know is
that it could be controlled by a human
as well and in that mode it is capable
of much more than just fancy party
tricks it it is a serious platform and
Boston Dynamics first commercial robot
with actual industrial applications now
there's another robot under the Boston
Dynamics umbrella whose name personifies
robotic deafness it is called the handle
although it looks like the engineers
didn't use their creativity when it
comes to naming the robot they
definitely made an extremely dexterous
robot and to top it off gave it Wheels
the robot stands at 6.5 feet high and
can travel at 9 miles an hour the energy
efficient robot also runs on a battery
and can travel at a remarkable speed of
15 miles per hour and did I mention that
the robot can also jump up to four feet
high
foreign
let's now move from land-based robots to
ones that can swim specifically let's go
to robot fish next Yes you heard that
right a robot that can mimic the
deafness of a fish named Sophie is the
recent Innovation on the table in
general it's estimated that we humans
have only explored around 20 percent of
our planet's oceans and the life living
within them however the deep blues
aren't something you should play with
and could be extremely dangerous for
explorers the obvious solution to
overcome this crisis is to build
something which not only has a close
resemblance to the ecosystem underneath
the waves but can also move definitely
in its environment researchers at MIT
have now tested Sophie in deep diving
conditions and have gathered data from
various missions to conclusively say
that the robot fish can easily deep dive
handle High currents and take high
resolution photos and videos using its
fisheye lens yes the pun is not lost on
me Robert katzman the head of this MIT
research in computer and Science and
artificial intelligence laboratory said
to our knowledge this is the first
robotic fish that can swim underneath in
three dimensions for extended periods we
are extremely excited about the
possibility of using a system like this
to get closer to marine life than humans
ever could on their own scientists hope
that Sophie could be the light at the
end of the tunnel regarding forever
mysteries of oceans and their Wildlife
sticking with the theme of underwater
exploration another Innovative solution
to our deep sea exploration problems is
the ocean one robot from Stanford it's a
humanoid that functions as a robotic
diver controlled by a human on the
surface the robot is capable of diving
into areas that are too hazardous for
humans and are likely to be too
hazardous for conventional autonomous
deep sea exploration Vehicles as well
it's specially designed to undertake
dangerous Expeditions like exploring
shipwrecks and studying deep sea
oceanological activities ocean 1 allows
operators to dive virtually and be their
physical representation underwater the
robot is designed to be highly dexterous
and can virtually undertake all actions
that a human diver might on top of that
it can also deliver haptic feedback to
the controllers making the entire
experience very realistic well I have
now spoken a lot about robotic dexterity
let's jump into the next category which
is robotic utility when it comes to
robotic utility Honda's Asimo is the
Pioneer in this field Honda has been
developing the advanced step in
Innovative Mobility or a SEMO robots for
over 20 years and now they can make
sense of their environment via facial
and sound recognition and if you thought
that was cool the rest of what the robot
could do would definitely blow your mind
it can understand basic social cues like
handshakes pointing and waving making
the robot extremely easy to interact
with they're currently being used as
waiters in a fully automated restaurant
in Japan interestingly the robot can
also detect the movement of multiple
objects in its sphere of senses and it
can automatically calculate their
distance and Direction allowing it to
take specific preemptive actions such as
avoiding something or moving out of
someone's way automatically just imagine
the amount of computation that is
required to undertake an activity such
as this from a robot that's why Asimo
gets the top spot in the list of robotic
utility but that's not all it has the
ability to recognize General sounds like
objects falling or other loud noises so
the chances of sneaking up to it seem to
be slim the two cameras that make up its
eyes can detect facial expressions and
can follow a face or turn its head to a
person during a conversation across the
board a SEMO demonstrates robotic
utility as it can perform General tasks
like turning on light switches opening
doors and carrying objects and pushing
carts Honda plans to fully integrate a
SEMO into human households in another
decade or so now sign me up for that the
next robot on this list of robotic
utility is a bit different it doesn't
demonstrate utility in the conventional
sense like a SEMO but its utility lies
in developing interest in the robotic
Sciences among the general population
and to be honest if humanity is to
interface with robots moving the
development and education out of the
labs and into our homes is perhaps the
best way to go about it I am of course
talking about opencat a fascinating
low-budget approach to robotics for
anybody who wants to learn the basics of
Robotics innovator Wong Zhong Lee
started the company petoy which develops
open cat to make these cost effective
but highly sophisticated robot
prototypes for anyone to use the open
cat system is made out of Open Source
Technologies allowing users to modify
and experiment with their robots
completely users can run simulations add
or subtract functionalities from their
robots and even in some cases totally
disassemble them and make something else
entirely the team at petoy is constantly
developing these programmable and highly
maneuverable quadruped robots for stem
education and even adding AI enhanced
features to them the compact design of
these robots not only makes them super
affordable to the consumer but they can
also perform various mammal-like
behaviors and react to their
surroundings its innovative soft joints
reduce wear and shocks and extend the
lifetime of the hardware our little
buddy there are mainly two versions that
users can choose based on their
technical competence one uses the
Arduino module for real-time programming
and sensor integration while there is
another more advanced model that runs on
a Raspberry Pi module that offers a lot
more programming control and
customization although not a house old
name yet like the ASIMO the opencam team
states that the end goal would be to
create a little robotic cat Alexa which
one can control using their smartphone
with an app store from where you can
download third-party applications making
it a highly sophisticated toy for the
21st century finally we take a look at a
robot that in my opinion is at the
Forefront of robotic Innovation and
demonstrates the possibilities of the
field in life-saving applications
robotic Innovation The Da Vinci surgical
system robot is an invention designed to
save lives this robot helps translate
surgeons movements into smaller more
precise ones Da Vinci's surgeries are so
precise as they use tiny instruments
inside the patient's body which is a
total Game Changer in the field of
medicine it is the most famous surgical
robot in the world and its success
stories in performing complex surgical
operations are the stuff of Legend the
robot has two parts a tower where the
robotic arm operates and a separate
console through which the surgeon
controls the robotic arm the tower is
positioned directly over the person
during surgery and is directly equipped
with four separate actuated arms three
of them have all of the surgical
instruments and the fourth one is
equipped with a 3D camera on the other
end at the console a surgeon manipulates
these forearms using a very special
joystick that allows the surgeon to use
his or her fingers to translate very
minute and precise movements to Da
Vinci's surgical instrument all the
while viewing the insides of the patient
using a stereoscopic monitor you must
have already seen this video going viral
of a robot doing surgery on a grape yes
it was the da Vinci system The Da Vinci
is genuinely one of the most Innovative
robots out there that is not just
experimental but has real-world
implications it is currently used for
cardiac surgery head and neck surgery
and various other sensitive surgeries
that were not possible before the Advent
of this robot so in that regard the
robot has definitely lived up to its
lofty name so there you have it a quick
look at all the Next Generation robots
out there today which among all these
robots was your favorite let me know in
the comments below if you want to learn
more about science and technology topics
click on on another video on the card
and I will see you in the next one